- So my friend Mark Rober has graduated
from detonating glitter
bombs on package thieves,
to actually catching scammers in the act.
And many of you will ask,
can Mark's evidence
actually be used in court?
And the answer is,
it depends, because it always depends,
but probably more likely than not.
There are a couple of
overlapping issues here.
Number one is chain of custody.
When you have evidence, you have to show
that it is what it purports
to be, and it's authentic.
And Mark can probably
demonstrate this through
lots and lots of videographic evidence.
- You can call my probation officer,
I don't know what's happened.
- And then there's the evidentiary issue.
A lot of these videos
are going to be hearsay.
It's technically considered
hearsay evidence.
But as you know, if
you watch this channel,
there are lots of exceptions
and they probably apply here.
And then finally there
are statutory things,
like rules against videotaping people,
privacy laws, and here
it gets a little dicey,
but query whether you have
an expectation of privacy
if you're engaged in
manifest illegal activity.
But this is going to change,
it's going to be case by case.
Good for Mark for taking the initiative
and trying to catch
some of these bad guys.
It's fascinating.
Go watch his video,
or I'll see you in court.